new details on a case we've been
covering for a while here at cbs news
vincent simmons was released from a
louisiana prison in february after
spending 44 years behind bars for a
crime he says he did not commit
our lead national correspondent david
bagno you'll recall this was by his side
when a judge ruled he did not get a fair
trial the first time simmons was
convicted in 1977 of attempted
aggravated rape of twin sisters sharon
and karen sanders he's always maintained
his innocence this case is the focus of
this week's 48 hours season finale and
david spoke with one woman who claims
she knows the truth about what happened
freedom when vincent simmons walked out
of the louisiana state penitentiary
earlier this year
he felt vindicated
[Music]
vincent was found guilty in 1977 in
marksville louisiana of two counts of
attempted aggravated rape and sentenced
to 100 years in prison i was shocked
guilty i did nothing a judge vacated his
conviction after finding that vincent
did not receive a fair trial though the
judge did not make a finding as to
whether or not vincent is innocent or
guilty but identical twins karen and
sharon sanders insist that vincent raped
them when they were 14 years old and he
was 25. i know exactly who raped me that
night
the twins say they were with their then
18 year old cousin keith labord when
they encountered vincent at a gas
station and keith agreed to give vincent
a ride
they say vincent directed them to this
road where he forced keith into the
trunk of the car and then raped the two
of them the limitations it put on our
life
like with the anxiety it's taken a lot
from us i looked at the discovery i was
like well everything they said at trial
is a lie
it's all a lie
justin bonus vincent simmons current
attorney is skeptical he believes that
the twins are lying to protect keith
labord with me right now keith's cousin
dana bruyette told a private
investigator in 2020 and swore in an
affidavit that keith admitted to her
that vincent simmons was never with them
that night he came out and told me there
was never
a black man
instead in that affidavit dana says that
keith told her
he had consensual sex with one of the
girls and locked the other in the trunk
he liked sharon and trump
and he said the sex between him and
karen was consensual
he said but the other one was a little
hell cat that's the one that put the
scratches on your neck
in the affidavit dana says that keith
had scratches on his neck she told the
private investigator that she believes
keith and the twins made up the story
about a black man
to explain away those scratches karen
and sharon deny that but in a stunning
admission karen does acknowledge having
had consensual sex with keith years
before the twins say they were attacked
but that has nothing to do with what
vinson did that's two
separate incidents
i called keith to ask him about all of
this
hello keith this is david begno with cbs
news keith now 63 years old denied ever
having sex with karen he said they just
quote played around like children end
quote and he also insisted that whatever
had happened between the two of them had
nothing to do with what vincent simmons
did that night okay
he's guilty i don't get and yeah he's
like
and you can put that on tv i ain't
scared of them
wow david bakenow joins us now uh david
good morning uh i want to talk about
vincent first he's out of prison what's
life been like for him uh tough you know
he's trying to get used to just the
basic stuff i mean he's been enjoying
every moment but it's also um been
challenging i mean he went into prison
when he was 25 years old walked out
three days before his 70th birthday so
so much has changed since then we were
there with him in the days after his
release and he was just trying to you
know flicker around with the remote
control and figure out the basic
automation that we've lived through
using a cell phone for the first time
all things he's never experienced before
he left prison with next to nothing just
boxes of pictures letters legal
documents that he had accumulated behind
bars so it's certainly been a big
adjustment does vincent plan to go back
to court to seek compensation for
wrongful imprisonment so it's
interesting his attorney says he does
intend to go back to court but under
louisiana state law vincent is only
entitled to compensation if he can
present clear and convincing evidence of
his innocence and it's important to note
that when the judge vacated vincent's
conviction he did not make a finding as
to whether or not vincent is innocent
guilty he really only found that venison
vincent didn't receive a fair trial it
seems like they would be synonymous
those two things uh you would think but
the legal distinction is clear
it's so messy and so tawdry you know
allegations of sleeping with your cousin
i could see why you would not want
anybody to ever know that about you but
was there any other evidence other than
the words of the words of karen and
sharon and the cousin
zero zero none no physical evidence it's
all based on their word and karen told
us she goes listen i think i was nine or
ten years old when we experimented like
kids
uh but but still i mean what a stunning
revelation
that is so relevant of course to
the story and the word of the other
relative that said keith told them
keith told them and speaking relevant
what's law enforcement saying about
these allegations exactly so look law
enforcement when we called the district
attorney i actually said to him i said
you know sir karen admitted that she had
had consensual sex with keith when you
know keith was a little bit older than
her but she was around nine or ten and
karen told us she thinks that you know
they had consensual sex and admitted he
said listen david that's problematic but
he said at the end of the day i still
think vincent's guilty i don't think
keith did it and so the district
attorney is standing by the women
wow i really admire the attorney justin
you know what's amazing gail really
admire him he and his wife new york city
watched a documentary about the case he
called vincent said i want to help you
after 20 years of trying vince it's like
okay guy come on yeah and he did it yeah
he was the game-changer justin bonus i
think he's one of the heroes too in this
story yeah don't disagree i like how you
called him skeptical he seems more than
skeptical he's pretty convinced at this
point exactly
48-hour season finale tomorrow night i'm
going to say that too david thank you
very much
david's report please don't tell on the
48 hours what is it david season finale
tonight oh tomorrow night 10 9 central
right here on cbs and on our streaming
service paramount plus